[Musik]
hey was geht ab jetzt willkommen bei
einem rockstar bayern ein video
ja ich hoffe natürlich geht's gut
gestern kam ein video zehn kostenlose
produkte im test in dem video habe ich
schon gesagt ich habe in zukunft
irgendwie mal wieder bock sachen zu
bestellen die zu testen macht halt mega
spass wenn ihr sagt das wollen wir auch
dass wir jetzt die daumen nach oben da
würde ich mich wirklich sehr darüber
freuen und heute haben wir ein ganz
besonderes thema erst wahrscheinlich
haben diese schon gelesen es geht
nämlich um amazon produkte mit einer
stern bewertung war das jetzt gerade
grammatikalisch richtig keine ahnung mit
einer stern bewertung heißt so viel wie
schlechte produkte also sachen die
gekauft wurden die käufer waren absolut
nicht zufrieden und haben eine böse
rezension gegeben mit einem stern aber
amazon kann man ja von eins bis fünf
sternen bewerten und ich habe wirklich
sehr lange gesucht bis ich den kamen
zusammen hatte das ganze ist da ich
würde euch gerne mal eine kleine
übersicht erstmal geben was ich dann
bestellt haben also viel spaß
ach so ja guten tag er soll so bald ich
wollte euch mal kurz im schnelldurchlauf
zeigen was ich alles bestellt habe und
schauen warum das ganze nur einen stern
hat das ding ist jetzt ich habe das
ganze vor drei tagen bestellt wenn ich
pech habe hat vielleicht eine sache
jetzt nicht mehr nur einen stern
aber wir werden sehen die badehose ist
immer noch gut dabei und zwar haben wir
hier einmal diese badehose ja die hat
einen stern habe ich überhaupt nicht
verstanden wo sie herrin badeshorts ich
finde die sind eigentlich ganz cool aus
da hat jemand geschrieben als die
badehose zugeschickt wurde musste ich
leider fall verfällt feststellen dass
die badehose viel zu klein um haben
könnte dass die badehose viel zu klein
ausfällt und damit ungeeignet ist bis zu
dumm dass willkommen in deutschland der
typ heißt auch noch siegfried herrmann
ich brauche eine neue bade buchse stellt
die badehose in viel zu klein
passt nicht und ergibt dann einfach
einstellen weil er sie selber in viel zu
klein bestellt hat es ist doch deine
schuld und ich während ich sag mal so
wenn der bauer nicht schwimmen kann
liegt an der badehose dieser spruch
passt sehr gut zum herrn siegfried wird
als nächstes haben wir hier eine
kamera und zwar die albrecht mini action
kamera mit standfuß fand ich sehr
interessant für nur die hat eigentlich
nur 717 euro gekostet und sogar 2 gb sd
karte gibt es jetzt irgendwie nur noch
für 750 euro das habe ich nicht bezahlt
da hat jemand kommentiert absoluter müll
zwar schön verpackt und recht ansehnlich
aber der fokus lag mehr auf der funktion
des gerätes das datum lässt sich nicht
einstellen daher beginnen die kammer
nach jedem laden wieder im herbst 2007
produktionsdatum zu zählen und blendet
dieses falsche datum hätte ich nicht die
videos ein
die bildqualität entspricht ebenfalls
eine kamera und seit 2007 das mikro
zeichnet ein weißes rauschen auf
zwischendurch umgebungsgeräusche und
tiefen durchbrochen nach einer stunde
mit führen in der hosentasche haben sich
die aufdrucke wie ohne und vox johannes
westermann
also muss man sich merken weil ich so
kann ich das natürlich nicht mehr
zurückgeben
killer da die wir auch bestellt dann
haben wir hier diese kopfhörer auch
ebenfalls mit nur einem stern
ich war von keinem produkt jemals so
enttäuscht wie von inhaber in ihr stereo
kopfhörern die sogenannte in ear
kopfhörer sind nichts weiter als
billiger standard ohrhörer mit
aufgesetzter gummischlauch dann haben
wir hier eine uhr mit der überschrift
toilettensitze höher zeigt für
krankenschwestern eine kundenrezensionen
die uhr hatte länger nach kurzer zeit
der benutzung dagegen irgendwann nichts
mehr mehrmals habe ich die batterie
ausgetauscht
also um die uhr soll auf schrott sein
dann haben wir hier eine pen lite stift
lampe in silber wo kommentiert wurde da
ist keine sparsame led eingebaut wie in
der produktplanung angedeutet einmal auf
den schalter gedrückt und vergessen sind
die batterien leer
nach zwei mal runterfallen war dann auch
die glühbirne hin dann haben wir hier
eulenspiegel läuft color haarspray guck
mal hier ist jetzt das einem stern
eineinhalb geworden
es tut mir leid ich habe das gestellt
hatte dass nur ein stern am darm halt
alle geschrieben
dass das einfach nur schlechtes produkt
ist was nicht verspricht was draufsteht
dass es stinkt lebt und so weiter
schnell geliefert und große enttäuschung
stinkendes fast ohne erkennbaren blauen
effekt eigentlich habe ich hier noch
dieses schöne trikot bestellt ist leider
noch nicht angekommen war mir jetzt egal
das sind die sachen nicht bestellt habe
und wir testen so leute willkommen
zurück
wir haben jetzt hier insgesamt sechs
sachen doch nicht deswegen wie sie da
irgendwas fehlt wir werden am ende sehen
was es ist und ich will gar nicht lange
lagern gefangen direkt machen und dann
werden wir natürlich sehen ist diese
eine ständige recht oder absolut
unverdient
dann schreibe ich mal eine ordentliche
rezension zu ich würde einfach mal sagen
wir fangen hier mit an das ist ja ich
bin mal gespannt was jetzt so leute hier
hatten wir den led was auch immer das
ding kann handlicher kugelschreiber
design ultra helles licht niedriger
batterie verbraucht wo das ist also ein
ding mit dem man dann halt auch im
dunkeln schreiben kann ich habe keine
ahnung was ich mega geil finde ich sind
schon batterien dabei das kann man ja
sonst nicht erwarten deswegen das ding
hat für euro gekostet beschwerden kann
man sich da normalerweise eher weniger
was ich nicht dass ich mich jetzt
schneide
jeder von euch der solche verpackungen
hast ich gehe jetzt mal nach oben
ich hab dann schauen wir mal die
hunderttausende gibt es da vielleicht
irgendein trick oder so lasse ich mich
gerne in den kommentaren wissen aber ich
hab's geschafft so und wir haben hier
einen stift der leuchtet wofür das jetzt
genau gebraucht wird kann ich gar nicht
mal so wirklich sagen guck mal leuchtet
sogar echt stark ich finde ich geil
warum der typ jetzt einen stern gegeben
hat keine ahnung
leute wir machen weiter mit dem nächsten
produkt hier wurde sich ordentlich
beschwert und gemeckert wir haben das
hair colour von eulenspiegel einen
spiegel profi schminkt farbe gmbh das
soll im dom
die haare zum leuchten bringen aber
eigentlich nur gesagt dass das grausam
stinkt also ich finde es gibt schlimm
wenn man jetzt so an karneval oder
fasching denkt je nachdem wie ihr das
land früher meine haare immer ultra
gesammelt von so zeugs das probiere ich
am schluss ich will jetzt nicht meine
opfer kommen wir machen das mal kurz
ganz leicht hier in die haare rein
vielleicht fangen ja dann gleich an zu
leuchten
irgendwie sieht das graue maus man also
zweites produkt finde ich jetzt auch
nicht mega schlecht natürlich doch es
hat eine wirkung als nächstes das ist
natürlich schlau
jetzt kommt mir nämlich doch auch sechs
produkte hier wurde einmal die uhr und
die kopfhörer zusammengepackt das hier
ist diese toilette oder wie auch immer
sie heißen heute mit spiegel dran ich
frage mich jetzt gerade nur wie man das
ding auflegt oder ist zum laufen bringt
ich habe keine ahnung wahrscheinlich
gibt es irgendein trick an die uhren
freaks unterreicht schreibt gerne in die
kommentare
auf jeden fall geht die uhr nicht eine
person schild 7 euro da würde ich jetzt
auch nicht mehr als zum stern geben
jetzt jack warner für die kopfhörer die
wurden ja auch draußen in den boden
gestampft so wir haben hier wunderschöne
kopfhörer die wirklich
sehr langes kabel haben dass sich
vermutlich dann in jeder tasche dreimal
um sich selber wickelt also die qualität
von denen es echt nicht gut weg ich
jetzt schon kurz mal gucken wie die sich
im ohr anfühlen leute jetzt nehme ich
euch mal kurz hier mit kommen jetzt hier
in mein blick rein und jetzt starte ich
jemanden geilen im dreck ach du scheiße
oha junge junge junge dass für sieben
euro also ohne lange zu überlegen das
sind wirklich schlechtesten kopfhörer
die hier hatte und so weit ich mich
erinnern kann sind die von welcher marke
von hama ist das nicht eigentlich sogar
irgendwas mit ein bisschen qualität oder
es ist ein baumarkt das gibt es auch
meine haare leuchten nicht sie werden
von dem zeug also kopfhörer ein stern
mehr hat das ding mehr das zeug nicht
verdient kann ich absolut nachvollziehen
komplett scheiße als nächstes kommen
hierzu action kämen die habe ich für 17
euro erschossen hat leider auch nur ein
stern kommt wohl aus dem jahr 2007 da
ist sogar eine 8 gigabyte sd karte
möglich war
ich habe gar keine abgabe speicherkarte
bei mir fängt es so ab 32 an
ich hätte dir jetzt echt größer
eingestuft der typ meint er das weiss
sofort ab wenn man drüber geht so hier
haben wir einige halterung für das zeug
das stand ja sogar da ist eine zwei
gigabyte speicherkarte dabei die frage
ist jetzt wurden arkona die ist hier
schon drin ja wirklich zwei gigabyte
dass ich sowas nochmal einen händen
halte hätte ich bis zum heutigen tage
auch nicht gedacht dass so etwas
überhaupt noch produziert wird ist auch
kratzer ich war speicherkarten bis zu
einem terabyte schon
und die kommen hier mit zwei gigabyte an
was das denn ich habe das gefühl ich
muss die erst mal kurz laden
das werden wir auch tun ihr könnt
übrigens mal kurz in der zwischenzeit in
die kommentare schreiben auch was wir
bestellt wie das hättet ihr noch bock
außer so zufällig bestellen das will ich
nicht mehr machen irgendwelche spontanen
ideen wie zum beispiel die sie jetzt nur
ein sterne produkte bestellen schreibt
es mir in die kommentare so das ding
lebt ein paket haben wir noch das ist
glaube ich die ware wurde die da
siegfried müller mit einem stern
bewertet hat absolute frechheit
ich bin mal gespannt findet sich auf
jeden fall gar nicht mal schlecht dran
ich habe in der größe m gestellt und ich
denke gerade der name siegfried müller
passt zu einem siegfried müller seine
badehose irgendwie nicht oder also ich
finde ich irgendwie ziehen mal kurz an
also also es ist eigentlich ganz gut das
einzige was ein bisschen blöd ist hier
die naht das könnte wirklich schnell
aufreißen aber für mich wenn ich jetzt
auf jeden fall vier sterne drin
einer ist ja echt ist eine frechheit
weil sie kriegt wenn du das siehst dich
kriege ich noch so also wir haben
zusammen sechs sachen und getestet die
kamera fehlt noch das spray ob ich würde
sagen dass balle ich mir jetzt mal kurz
in die haare und nehme den rest gleich
mit der action cam ob also die endkappen
video kann natürlich sein dass sie dann
absolut nichts mehr versteht hier eine
2007 steht und das bild ja auch an das
jahr 2007 erinnert deswegen würde ich
sagen
damit geht doch jetzt schon mal einen
fetten daumen nach oben
werden die jetzt blau leuchten im
dunkeln
das check jetzt so kurz mit dieser
kamera hier ab und dann sehen wir uns
morgen übermorgen hat halt also läuft
und tut hier absolut gar nichts die sind
jetzt grau blau was auch immer bei einer
kann etliche frust auf jeden fall
verstehen das ist wirklich nicht gut
also alles klebt stinkt das hier tun
auch nicht viel meine hasen blau oder
was auch immer das sein soll dann muss
ich wirklich auch in dicken nach unten
geben hauptsache meine finger sind jetzt
lila schön dank leute ich habe jetzt
extra noch drei stunden gewartet dieses
dringend geht nicht an ich mache es die
ganze zeit an eigentlich müsste es oben
jetzt grün leuchten tut es nicht ich
weiß nicht warum aber ich scheiße wenn
man irgendwas testen will und das dann
nicht mehr funktioniert also von mir
gibt es da auch null sterne
das geht gar nicht ich finde dass gerade
echt mega schade weil ich wollte
eigentlich wirklich diese videoqualität
jetzt hier noch haben also von der
kamera mache ich dann vielleicht im
nächsten paar also wenn er sagt man auf
jeden fall noch ein paar davon lassen
doch nach oben da und hat rein ich
wünsche euch schönen abend